it is time for hatred mail what is
hatred mail this is hatred mail we're
getting to the oranges of this
investigation so god bless United
sasirekha Patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom
this week's hatred mail introduces a new
term we've talked a lot about
impeachment on the program as a possible
means to remove Donald Trump although I
don't believe that it will today we are
introducing a new term take a listen to
this impressment s-- will not get Trump
out of office it will backfire
spectacularly and propel him to a
landslide victory
I can't believe David Pakman admitted to
being evil progressives reveal in their
Navy vet as though at some kind of
innocence Trump is behind you David feel
the love hello
see what I did there I guess this long
common qualifies me as unhinged you know
I have to say I agree with the hatred I
don't believe that imp Richmond is going
to remove Trump I just don't don't see
it happening and I think we've got
another urban dictionary word that could
maybe be added in with the definition
referencing the David Pakman show
imprint I and all hatreds seem to be
united we will not remove Donald Trump
from the but White House with imp
Richmond and I encourage you to pass the
word along make sure to fight hate reott
ism by using the coupon code hatred for
tea when you sign up for a membership at
join pakman.com you go to WWE pakman.com
you choose a monthly or a yearly
membership of your choice doesn't matter
which one you hit the red signup button
and when you're offered the possibility
of inserting a coupon code you put in
hey tree at 40 that's H 80
RI o T 4-0 hey tree at 40 your
membership price will be instantly
dropped by 40% and hey tree
it's see this as a failing of their hate
reott ISM when people here hate reott
mail and instead of abandoning the David
Pakman show they instead go to our
website and sign up with the coupon code
hatred for tea this is just so
devastating for hatreds that I encourage
all of you find folks to do it